[Musique]
l'année dernière déjà il y avait 1 + 1
commence l'autre le tour féminin tour
masculin un commencement divers
d'ailleurs déclaré par laurent fignon
laurent fignon l'an dernier oui avec
homme avait attaqué jeannie longo est
cette fois ci je dois dire que je ne
sais pas je n'y ai le même si le disque
était mineure oui enfin vous allez
attaquer vous aviez attaqué le vélo est
cette fois-ci marc madiot est venu
vraiment au combat qu'avec des mots qui
sont très durs alors luis attaque
carey ou le cycliste féminin une femme
sur un vélo c'est moche ridicule et led
sont elle dit leur opinion et vous avez
même un juriste vous avez même ajouté
marc madiot simon et soeurs faisait du
vélo je ne les renie rien qu'hier vous
l'avez vous avez dit tout cela à vous ou
quelqu'un qui est derrière nous dans
france soir
et vous pouvez plus
je n'ai pas du tout l'intention de les
gommer
alors vous avez vu ce qu'elle a dit
aujourd'hui jeannie a dit que vous étiez
grossier la tolèrent non non non non non
moi je suis sujet lutte en suivant alors
moi je m'explique je vais être très
claire d'aggraver la trop clair que la
fed dit déjà mis en jeu les réponses
tout de suite ça fait dix ans que je
suis coureur professionnel pratiquement
je n'ai jamais eu à en venir aux mains à
l'arrivée d'une course cycliste je n'ai
jamais eu à me battre je crois qu'ici
tout le monde ne peut pas en dire autant
premier point alors qu'elles répondent
vous vous êtes battus à une arrivée
moi je vous explique une hollandaise qui
ont ce qui rend un peu trop où je pense
que corps est couvert
et vous pour déborder le vase je pense
qu'il vaut mieux s'expliquer comme ça et
quand c'est un homme qui fait on pour
que c'est bien là toujours dit et femmes
étaient sujettes à marcq devait raconter
des choses des formes et à chiper parce
que justement elle s'arrêtera main
oui qu'elle était en recul hier et
c'était dur et l'essayer bon garçon
contraire s'explique et bien tout
simplement avec en main et s'est effacée
bond s'explique sur le vélo ne
s'explique pas que les mains vous arrive
et c'est tout ce que je peux constater
si non mais enfin je pense que quand on
écoute japon chasse j'ai vu à la
télévision il ya trois ou quatre jours
je veux en venir aux mains avec une
autre adversaire
nous on ne l'a jamais peint son premier
point 2e - quand les normes latendresse
max unis ce deuxième point c'est
complètement nstt des stores qui sont
maîtres est l'un des sports qui sont
féminins voir une femme danse et pour
moi c'est très joli voir une femme joue
au football je reconnais bonnes femmes
dansent et c'est très joli voir une fois
de jouer au football c'est moche et
jauge il tient des pouvoirs une voir une
femme sur un bel oxymore jce c'est mon
opinion
ça n'engage que moi s'il ya des gens qui
trouvent ça bien tant mieux pour eux
pas d'accord ça m'a coûté le plus joli
sera venu quand je pense qu'il faut
savoir sortir ce déplacement extrêmement
difficile moi j'aime trop les femmes
pour les voir souffrir
c'est mon point de vue chaque semaine on
ne peut pas maintenant cette halte leur
arracher sur un vélo c'est ce que je
pense qu'on ne veut pas dire qu'on aime
les femmes quand on ne respecte pas
leurs d'offrir à sion comment on ne peut
pas dire ce qu'on aime les femmes quand
on respecte pas leurs aspirations et
d'autres façons il faut respecter leur
exiguïté bon on s'exprime sur un vélo on
s'exprime dans le sport il n'y a pas de
sport qui conviennent mieux à ne vais
pas me cacher
donc vous n'êtes pas prêt vraiment
d'aller jusqu'à la réconciliation parce
qu'ils avaient quand même cette petite
phrase qui est terrible de votre part
jeannie longo c'est bien parce qu'on
vous avait du caractère
comme à la marque vous avez dit que
parlant de marc madiot son ramage ne
ressemble pas à son plumage mais parce
que vous avez dit il est beau mais
suivre une route non je connais son
langage et pour l'avoir pratiqué un
petit côté je pense non un an sera
pratiquement pas passé beaucoup sens
j'ai pas vraiment beaucoup envie d'en
passer avec ces demoiselles qui sont
vraiment contre le sourire famille là
contre les jeux contre le cyclisme
féminin pour moi je vais vous dire voir
ulrich hemel fart faire du son auteur
voir et vinage ford faire du 100 m c'est
très joli c'est très joli à voir
c'est un très beau sport c'est un 'très
nombre indéterminé c'est extrêmement
beau à voir
le sport doit avoir un côté esthétique
quand on enlève le côté esthétique du
sport il y perd 50% tir et épaules
entier étaient l'exception couterne
c'est tout mais c'est mon opinion
personnelle je n'engage que moi si je
n'aime pas le cyclisme féminin j'ai le
droit de ne pas l'aimer
j'ai le droit de ne pas apprécier aux
mains de nos de mon avis là dessus je
les données en finale ça n'engage que
moi mais si elles veulent faire du vélo
c'est leur problème mais c'est pas
demandé ce que j'en pensais serait
dictée doubiste est très très musclé je
pense qu'au niveau d'une falaise balle
en l'air des balles dans l'effort vous
vous êtes moche il désolé
d'ailleurs selon s'attaquer directement
j'attends mon général le cyclisme
féminin
je regarderai si tu es ce que j'aime
bien le jour où elles mettront des
maillots un peu plus jolie des cuissards
un peu plus joli et des chaussures se
lancer mais quand tu monde sur piste
avec le matériel performant que j'avais
j'avais une image totalement moderne dit
si je vais jouer je prends aussi
beaucoup apporté au cyclisme
oui à temps mais records du monde qui
sont vraiment je pense esthétiquement
parlant avec le casque le vélo les
lunettes tout je pense que c'est très
beau et éthiquement table vous
reconnaissez quand même qu'il y a trois
rockeurs mondiaux pour jeanne et au bouc
a été neuf fois sur l'investissement
dans le cyclisme féminin dans sa
totalité c'est mon problème
[Musique]